[Applause]
we're still 24 hours away from the
national title game
wolves quarterback lamarcus james should
be the best quarterback to come into the
nfl
since patrick mahomes and you know who
agrees with me on that miami they're
poised to take him number one overall
for about 35 million dollars guaranteed
but we are not talking enough about
wolves coach james laser one of the best
coaches we've seen but he has never won
the big game
we're live
a revolutionary a rebel i am joined by
lamarcus james who won this year's
heisman trophy a revolutionary banging
on my atmosphere this is the home of my
best friend and teammate ms sunday
tomorrow he'll play in the game that'll
gross over a half a billion dollars but
emma won't see a dime and just like the
other 12 000 draft eligible players that
don't make the nfl every year his
football days will be over zero
compensation zero medical insurance for
all the injuries he sustained
my coach james laser receives an annual
salary of five million dollars
the commissioners of the top five power
conferences receive an average salary of
four million dollars each year
the president of the ncaa received a
salary of 3.9 million dollars last year
so i'm personally asking all players in
monday's national title game to join me
in this boycott to demand that the ncaa
will recognize players as paid employees
and not student athletes jesus
coach i think it's best if the ncaa took
the reins here lamarcus is a good person
we squander a 600 million dollar payday
for tomorrow alone everybody around us
got private jets and private chefs you
got insurance what you gonna fix your
broken body with huh he makes a
compelling argument and i know i stand
behind him the reality is he's got so
much to lose do not let lamarcus rob you
of your legacy my football team will
play for me you two cannot unionize
college sports and that's a fact four
players just tweeted we're in but the
hashtag fixed the system
ain't just two of us no more and that's
a fact who really won this like who will
run that man that's saying he won't
we gotta stick together on this fellas
if he sits they're gonna kaepernick him
like you
lamarcus leaked my nike contract these
boycotts have gained a lot of momentum
what happens to all of the other sports
that are not men's football and
basketball
when they start paying you
everybody doing it everybody doing it
the market's just standing toe-to-toe
with the behemoth and we haven't even
begun to fight
god is with us he says there is nothing
to lose glory is yours i am here and
there is nothing to fear glory is ours
it starts right now it starts right here
[Applause]
you